the next opening we're going to be
looking at is probably the most popular
opening for black against Pawn to E4 and
that is the Sicilian Defense by far the
most popular defense for Grand Masters
it it's not only the most popular but it
actually scores the best as far as
Black's winning percentage so you'll
usually see this a lot there's a lot of
ways a lot of different variations of
the Sicilian Defense you've got the
nidorf you've got the dragon you've got
your classical you've even got The
Accelerated dragon all these different
things I I've made videos on all these
but but more than anything you should
definitely be familiar with the Sicilian
Defense there's different gambits that
you have uh but this is definitely going
to be one of the most common openings in
chess that everyone should definitely
know and have it in their top 10 chess
openings that they know in
chess